[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم مشاهدينا الكرام انا طاهر البركه
احييكم وانا راويه القاسم وهذه العربيه
عدو اوكرانيا الحقيقيه وصل الثلوج تغطي
اكياف والسلاح ينفذ منها روسيا قد تلجا
لتعبئه جديده
[موسيقى]
اسود الاطلس يقتربون من تحقيق انجاز
مونديال 86
تاهلي للدوري الثانيه
[تصفيق]
اطباء ايراني
لاعينهم وابنه شقيقه خامنئي تدعو العالم
لتضييق الخناق على النظام
وتتابعونا معنا الليله ايضا
[موسيقى]
ظهور جديد لابنه زعيم كوريا الشماليه
اثناء الدعايه لصاروخ بالستين الوريثه
[موسيقى]
ما كان يخشى منه الاوكرانيون طوال الاشهر
الماضيه اصبح واقعا لقد وصل الشتاء
وتساقطت ثلوج بغزاره في العاصمه
الاوكرانيه كاف مع انخفاض درجات الحراره
الى ما دون الصفر
لها بعد ان استهدفتها روسيا على مدار
الاشهر الماضيه الامر الذي ينظر بايام
صعبه
تجري استعدادات لموجه ثانيه من التعبئه في
صفوف قواتها تبدا في العاشر من ديسمبر
روسيا مرحله ثانيه من المعارك لاستغلال
ظروف الشتاء القاسيه على الاوكرانيين
الذين يبدو انه في حاجه ماسه الى السلاح
اذا الغرب يندفع لملئ المخزون الاوكراني
من السلاح من الاستعداد في ظل طبعا
الاستعداد لمعركه الشتاء التي قد تكون
حاسمه لاحد الطرفين تسعه اشهر مرات على
الحرب في اوكرانيا
يستنزفان ما لديهما من ذخيره واعتاد ومعه
تتسارع وتيره الدعم الغربي مسؤولون في
النت وقالوا ان كميه المدفعيه المستخدمه
مذهله ضاربين مثلا بافغانستان التي كانت
فيها قوات الحلف تطلق ما لا يزيد عن 300
قذيفه مدفعيه في اليوم بينما في اوكرانيا
يتم اطلاق الالاف من الطلقات يوميا مع
حاجتكاف المستمره للصواريخ ومضادات الدفاع
الجوي اضاف المسؤولون ان يوم القتال في
اوكرانيا باتا يوازي شهرا او اكثر من
القتال في افغانستان للمقارنه الاوكرانيون
اطلقوا الصيف الماضي في منطقه دومباز ما
بين سته الاف وسبعه تلقى مدفعيه كل يوم
بينما تنتج الولايات المتحده مثلا نحو
15000 قذيفه شهريه لذلك يسعى الغرب للعثور
على معدات وذخيره من الحقابه السوفيتيه
لتتمكن اوكرانيا من استخدامها بما في ذلك
صواريخ الدفاع الجوي اس 3 ودبابات تي 72
اضافه لقذائف المدفعيه من الطراز السوفيتي
اذا فالغرب
انظمه بديله حتى لو كانت اقدم لتحل محل
تقلص مخزونات صواريخ الدفاع الجوي الغربيه
باهضه الثمن حتى ان بعض النقاشات تدور حول
استثمارته في المصانع القديمه في جمهوريه
تشيك وسلوفاكيا وبالغاريه لاعاده تصنيع
قذائف من العهد السوفيتي وتزويدي اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
المحاولات الغربيه دونها عقبات كثيره في
وقت تعمل فيه بعض هذه الدول على تجاوز اي
امر قد يعيق التصدير لاوكرانيا توجد مثلا
مشكله الضوابط القانونيه على الصادرات
والتي تحكم اذا كان يمكن ارسال الاسلحه
والذخيره المباعه سلفا الى دوله اخرى في
حاله حرب هذا من الاسباب التي دفعت
السويسريين بدعوه انها دوله محايده الى
رفض السماح لالمانيا بالتصدر الى اوكرانيا
بعدما ارادت المانيا رساله ذخيره مضاده
للطائرات بيعت لها وهي من صنع السويسري
ايضا ايطاليا لديها قيود مماثله على
صادرات الاسلحه المصنعه محليا لديها عقب
اخرى بحسب مسؤول في نيته تحدث
لان الدول الصغيره
يشمل 20 دوله من اصل 30 في الحلم بينما
الدول العشره المتبقيه هي القادره التقديم
المزيد من فرنسا المانيا ايطاليا وهولندا
اذا في المجمل قدم الدول النت حتى الان
حوالي 40 مليار دولار من الاسلحه الى
اوكرانيا وهو ما يقرب من حجم ميزانيه
الدفاع السنويه لفرنسا على الجانب الاخر
روسيا تواجه ايضا مشاكل اعاده الامداد وهم
يستخدمون الان عددا اقل من قذائف المدفعيه
رغم وجود الكثير منها لديهم وتحاول موسكو
في مواجهه الدعم الغربي زياده انتاجها
العسكري بينما تفيد التقارير انها تسعى
لشراء صواريخ من كوريا الشماليه والمزيد
من الطائرات المسيره رخيصه الثمن من ايران
لكن حتى لو تم تدليل كل العقبات ووصل
السلاح الى اوكرانيا ستبقى معدي الى اخرى
يا طاهر سنتعرف عليها بعد
هذه المعضيه تتعلق بنتائج الانتخابات
النصفيه الامريكيه ومطالبه الجمهوريين
بالتدقيق في
المصدره لاوكرانيا ومراقبتها الهامش
الضئيل الاغلبيه الجمهوريه في مجلس النواب
دفعهم للتحذير من ان اداره الرئيس جوبيدا
عليها توقع اشراف اشد صرامه على المساعده
العسكريه المكثفه التي قدمتها الولايات
المتحده لاوكرانيا كما ان الضغط يتزايد
لتكثيف عمليات تعقب الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
وهو مقامت به اداره بايدن تحسبا لمثل هذه
المطالب من الجمهوريين متابعه ايضا في
الاسابيع الاخيره اعلنت الاداره عن جهودها
لتتبع شحنات الاسلحه كما حدد كل من وزاره
الخارجيه والبانتاجون الخطط بما في ذلك
المزيد من عمليات التفتيش والتدريب
للاوكرانيين والتي تهدف الى منع وقوع
الاسلحه الامريكيه في الايدي الخطا
نقلت عن محللين قولهم ان معظم الاطياف
السياسيه في واشنطن تتفق على ان الضغط نحو
المزيد من الرقابه امر جيد لكن الا يتحول
الى مجال للتنازع السياسي بين الجمهوريين
والديمقراطيين ذكرت الصحيفه بل ذكرت بحديث
زعيم الاقليه الجمهوريه كفن مكارثي عن ان
الولايات المتحده لا ينبغي ان تعطي
لاوكرانيا تشيكا على بياض كما طلبت ايضا
النائبه مارجوري تايلور جرين باجراء تدقيق
في برنامج المساعدات بعدما طلب بيض من
الكونجرس تخصيصا 37 مليار دولار لاوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
وعلى عكس الشكوك من جانب الحزب الجمهوري
يحاول بعض اعضاء
التوفيق بين وجهتي النظر النائب ديمقراطيه
عن
الضرائب الامريكيين يحق لهم معرفه اوجه
صرف اموالهم سواء كانت الاموال الموجهه
لاوكرانيه او لغيرها نوه النائب الى قانون
مراقبه تصدير الاسلحه الذي يفرض على
الاداره تقدم معقول بان متلقي المساعده
العسكريه يستخدمون الاسلحه للغرض المقصود
منها وبحسب شروط تحددها الولايات المتحده
في لجنه القوات المسلحه بمجلس النواب دفع
باتجاه ضروري
بانه من المحتمل ان توجد قيود مستقبليه
على نطاق المساعده التي يمكن ان توفرها
الولايات المتحده لكن بعضا من المشرعين
ومسؤولين بانتاج جون قالوا انه توجد
القليل من الاسباب الملموسه للقلق خاصه
وان اوكرانيا تقدم بشكل دوري تقارير تتحدث
عن كيفيه استخدام المساعده العسكريه
الامريكيه
هؤلاء المسؤولون يرون في المبادره
الاوكرانيه امرا مهما فيما يخص تتبع
الاسلحه الامريكيه الوارده اليها وتحديدا
الاسلحه الاكبر حجما وعيارا وليس الاسلحه
الصغيره التي تتسبب او تتسرب الى السوق
السوداء
له بعمليات تفتيش على الاسلحه في اوكرانيا
متى هو حيثما تسمح الظروف الامنيه قال
المتحدث باسم الوزاره
ليست بالقرب من خطوط المواجهه في الحرب
رافضا الادلاء بمزيد من التفاصيل حول
برنامج التفتيش
واشنطن بوست اشاره الى ان رصد مسار
الاسلحه يتم تعذيذه في حالات خاصه عندما
تحتوي الاسلحه المعنيه على التكنولوجيا
حساسه خاصه كصواريخ ستينجر
والدفاعات الجويه واجهزه الرؤيه الليليه
[موسيقى]
ينضم الينا من القاهره احمد علي بقى
الباحث في واحده دراسات الامنيه والعسكريه
في مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه اهلا بك ااا معنا استاذ
عليبه في هذه
النشره في العربيه 360 هل ترى اسباب
ملموسه تجعلك تعتقد بضروره التدقيق
والتفتيش او الحد من همم طبيعه بعض
الاسلحه الامريكيه المقدمه لاوكرانيا خوفا
من ان تقع في الايدي الخطا
بالتاكيد لانه هناك تجارب سابقه يعني حتى
في الحروب اللي كانت الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه طرف مباشر فيها زي افغانستان
والعراق كان بيحدث تسرب هائل للاسلحه خاصه
زي حضرتك ما ذكرت الجافلين والسنجر وبقى
اجهزه الرؤيه الليليه وغيرها من الاسلحه
اللي يمكن ان يحملها اشخاص وده امر وارد
ايضا في الحاله الاوكرانيه ربعه بشكل اصعب
او اكثر لانه القات الامريكيه مش موجوده
على الارض وبالتالي مساله المفتشين هنا هي
اللي بتثير امكانيه القدره على ضبط مساله
التتبع وفقا لقانون المستخدم النهائي او
قانون المستخدم الاخير لانه ما بيقدرش
يفتش اكثر من 10% في واقع الامر
وبيسلم السلاح من جنوب بولندا ورغم ان هم
عملوا بعض المشروعات الخاصه بال انه يتم
تدريب بعض القوات الاوكرانيه على هذا
المثال بداوا في بدايه الحرب كان في لا
بيتم فيها وضع مثل هذه الارقام الخاصه
بمسلسل الاسلحه وما الى ذلك ولكن بعد
شهرين ثلاثه كان الحقيقه في صعوبه في
النقطه تتم العمليه بشكل منظم على نحو ما
كانت موجوده عليه في البدايه مساله
الثانيه انه هذا الحرب تتلع قدر كبير جدا
من الاسلحه وايه يعني مش معروف متى سوف
تنتهي هذه الحرب وبالتالي بدات الاطراف
تثير هذه المساله ليس فقط الجانب الامريكي
لكن ايضا في القوه الاوروبيه بتقول انه
يعني لو تسربت هذه الاسلحه سيكون المتضرر
الاول منها هو الجانب الاوروبي مش بس
الجانب الامريكي وخاصه انه هناك مافيا
اوروبيه متخصصه في هذه المسائل تستطيع ان
هي تحصل على هذه الاسلحه هو ماذا لو وصل
نعم نعم يعني لناصلك عن النقطه التي
اثرناها بالعرض منذ قليل عن قيام الدول
الغربيه الان بالبحث عن اسلحه قديمه لدعم
اوكرانيا بها ايضا روسيا تستعمل اصلا
صواريخ قديمه من ايام الاتحاد السوفيتي
بهذه الحرب ولكن فعليا عدم قدره الدولتين
على تامين همم
الكم الكافي من القدرات العسكريه هل يمكن
ان يؤخر من اي عمليه عسكريه بريه بالقادم
من الايام
يعني
المفترض ان هو يعني ما يكونش في تاخير لو
انه مش هيكون فيه المزيد من شحنات الاسلحه
في الفتره المقدمه المقبله لانه بيكون فيه
نوع من التوازن اذا كان فيه هجوم على
الخطوط الاماميه من الجانبين واله حسب
مقدار التوسع او التمدد يعني اذا كانت
روسيا هتستكمل في منطقه الجمباز موجوده
النهارده في الجانب الشرقي من غير خرسان
فهي بتدور على الاسلحه او بيتحول ان هي
تسعى للانجازات الخاصه بهذا الاسلحه
وبالتالي مش هتكون محتاجه القدر كبير في
الشتاء كمان من الصواريخ اكثر ما هتكون
محتاجه للمدفعيه على الجانب الاخر همم
القوات الاوكرانيه فقدت تقريبا حوالي ثلث
المدفعيه اللي حصلت عليها من القوه
الغربيه واصبحت في مراكز الصيانه اللي
موجوده حاليا في بولندا وبالتالي هناك
يعني تقاسم لهذا المنزق ما بين الطرفين في
همم حقيقه الامر مثلا الاخرى انه بعض
الاسلحه او المهمه زي القفل الاستنجر
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه عندها نقص في
المخزون حتى اللي بتحتاجه وزاره الدفاع
الامريكيه لمده سنتين جايين وبالتالي مش
هتقدر حتى لا لقد مارتن ولا ريسون ولا
غيرها ان هي تقدر تعمل تعاقدات وده منظر
فضلا عن انه حتى القوه الاوروبيه نفسها هي
دلوقتي بتعيد تقييم منظومات التصالح
الخاصه بها فهي مش عايزه تخسر اسلحتها
اللي بتصنعها زي السويد او المانيا او
غيرها او سويسرا مقابل ان هي تطلع من
المخازن اللي كانت موجوده في دول الاتحاد
السوفيتي السابقه وتبدا تشغلها اعتبار ان
هي ما تفقدش اساحتها او حتى لا تصل يعني
تقنيات حديثه وتقع في ايدي ايضا مافيا
الصحه من جانب الاخر ما فيهم شكرا جزيلا
على كل هذه الاضاحات استاذ احمد علي بقى
باحث في واحده دراسات الامنيه والعسكريه
في مركز الاهرام للدراسات السياسيه
والاستراتيجيه شكرا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد وجه العشرات من اطباء
العيون في ايران رساله
الطبيه بسبب اصابتهم برصاص بنادق الصيد في
عيونها وفقد عدد كبير منهم البصره في عين
واحده او كلت العينين وكان 200 طبيب عيون
اصدر والاسبوع الماضي رساله مماثله تحذر
من فقدان البصر للمتظاهرين اصابتهم برصاصه
وفي ظل استمرار الاحتجاجات نشرت في سلطات
الايرانيه المزيد من قواتها في مدينه
بوكان الكرديه في محافظه اذربيجان الغربيه
بالتجامل مع احتجاجات المدن الكرديه
الاخرى الغربيه
[موسيقى]
لم يتبقى سوى اسبوعين وتدخل بعدها
احتجاجات ايران شهرها الثالث لا هدوء يلوح
في الافق تظاهرات عامه المدن الايرانيه
بجامعتها وطرقها ومحلاتها وحتى موظفيها
تمديدا بممارسات النظام القمعيه واحتجاجا
على مقتل الشاب سامي النظام الايراني
يمسكوا بزمام روايه واحده رسميه هذه المره
جدد اللواء حسين سلامه قائد الحرس الثوري
اتهام الغربي بالوقوف وراء الاحتجاجات
وبدل ان يصف المتظاهرين كما جرات العاده
بمثل الشغب اتجه الى القول انهم مغرر بهم
ادعاهم الى ان يعودوا لاحضان الدوله
وخلاله كلمته امام افراد قوات التعبئه
اعتمر سلام ان الولايات المتحده عدو خارجي
بل انها من العملاء الذين يحبون خطا شريره
لاسقاط النظام
حتى مرشد النظام علي خامنئي اسفه على مقتل
افراد قوه البسيج ونظر اليهم كمن ضحى
بروحه من اجل احداث شغب في ايراننا زعم ان
انت ان تدخل له في المرحله الاخيره وقع
لكي يحول دون تحول الشعب الايراني لمرتزقه
او لمرتهنين ما ينظر بان دفاع خامنئي عن
البسيج بهذا الشكل يمشي بان النظام
الايراني باتي ياخذ المظاهرات على محمل
الجد واعتبرها محلل سياسيون على انها
اقرار ضمني بفرضيات السقوط يضاف الى تلك
التصريحات ما اشار اليه المتحدث باسم
الحكومه الايرانيه علي بها دوري جهري الذي
عبر عن ارتياح لافراد قوات المسج الذين
يقودون المستقبل ويجعلون الاعداء خائفين
من الجيش الصاعد
[موسيقى]
ما شاء الله
[تصفيق]
[موسيقى]
محمود مراد
خاني مقطع فيديو لاخته من مكان اعتقالها
في طهران كانت
تشهر به صوتها ضد خالها الذي يواجه الشعب
بهذه الطريقه مناشده المجتمع الدولي بعدم
التزام الصمت حول جرائم النظام واطالبه
الحرس الثوري بالعوده الى رشده والانضمام
الى صفوف المدنيه
اي انسان
عن دعم هذا النظام قاتل للاطفال هذا
النظام لا يلتزم باي من المبادئ الدينيه
ولا يعرف قانون ولا قاعده للحكم سوى القوه
والمال ليحافظ على سلطته باي طريقه ممكنه
عن طريق استدعاء جميع ممثلين من ايران
وترضي كل منتسب لهذا النظام الوحشي كطريقه
للتعبير عن التضامن مع الشعب الايراني
وبينما تحتل التظاهرات صداره المشهد في
ايران يدخل المتضامنين في ركب الانتفاضه
دون ان يسلموا من يسلم فعليا من يد النظام
القمعي حيث اعلنت صدفات فاطمه زوجه الصحفي
الرياضي الايراني مهدي امير بور عن اعتقال
زوجها بسبب تضمنه مع الاحتجاجات ونقله الى
سجن افيل بطهران بعد ان هاجم الامن منزلهم
في الساعه الثانيه بعد منتصف الليل اما
خارج البلاد كشفت المخابرات الكنديه عن
تقارير تفيد بان الايرانيين المعارضين في
كندا تلقوا تحديدات عبر الرسائل النصيه
بلغتين الفارسيه والانجليزيه تطالبهم
بالامتناع عن نشر اي معلومه حول الانتفاضه
في وقت السابق اشتكى صحفيون ايرانيون في
بريطانيا من تهديداتنا وصفوها بالخطيره اذ
قال رئيس جهاز الامن الداخلي البريطاني
كين ما كالوم ان المخابرات الايرانيه
حاولت خطف وقت البريطانيين مقيمين في
بريطانيا على الاقل 10 مرات
صحفيه المقيمه خارج ايران عليه مسؤوليه
للاستفاده من حريه التعبير المتاحه لنا
هنا وفرصه الوصول الى الانترنت والاطلاع
على محتوى كبير ياتي من داخلها وهذا شيء
يزعج النظام الايراني الى حد كبير
الاجهزه
او عمليه اغتيال او شيء من هذا القبيل
وبحسب البيانات وكاله انباء نشطاء حقوق
الانسان هرانا قتل حتى يوم امس نحو 450
محتجا منهم 63 طفلا فضلا عن اعتقال اكثر
من 18 الفا من المتظاهرين وكذلك 156 مدينه
ايرانيه مسرحا لمناهض النظام بالرغم من
التعتيم على الاسماء الا ان الوكاله تعرفت
على هويه قرابه ثلاثه الاف من المعتقلين
كما مصدر النظام القضائي في ايران احكاما
باعدام سته محتاجين على الاقل منذ بدايه
الاحتجاجات ومع توجيه اتهامات للالاف بسبب
مشاركتهم في هذه الاضطرابات حسب ما ذكر
بيان المنظمه وحول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا
من بيكسل منى السلاوي الباحثه في الشان
الايراني اهلا بك معنا الليله سيده منى
يعني كلام قائد الحرس الثوري الايراني
اللواء حسن حسين سلامه بانه من يعتقد ان
النظام الايراني
على طاوله هذا النظام
سيناريو السقوط اصبح واردا يتم التداول به
طبعا يعني بعدها كل هذه الاشهر من
الاحتجاجات من الطبيعه ان يدخل ضمن ادبهم
كلام عن السقوط كما انه
محاولاتهم للتوجه الى الاصلاحين اذا هذا
يدل تخوفهم الشديد من الاسقاط يعني من
السقوط لذلك يذهبون الى افراد اللي هما
حذفوهم او اتهموهم بالخيانه همم ولكن يعني
في النهايه همم لا ننسى ان ديكتاتور للحظه
الاخيره يفكر انه لديه ضمان الامور ضمان
الامور يعني همم
المانيا كانت همم
وبرلين كانت محاصره وكان ما زال جوجلز همم
وزير الاعلام
هتلر كان يقول انهم منتصرون يعني هكذا
بالفعل الاعلام الديكتاتوريه
ولكن هناك مقومات لا يزال يعتمد عليها هذا
النظام في بقائه ما العنصر او العناصر
الاهم التي تعتقدين انه المتظاهرين بعولوا
عليها الان بمعنى انهم افقدوه للنظام
اياها او تلك التي يجب ان يفعلوا على
افقاده اياه
خلال تجربته تجاربه سابقا من الاحتجاجات
انه المجتمع الدولي ليس مهتمه كثيرا باصات
النظام الايراني يعني بكل احتجاجات ممكن
اهمها حركه الخضر رفعت شعر مطالبه طالب
الشارع الايراني دعم اوباما لاحتجاجاتها
ولكن اوباما التزم الصندو كل الاحتجاجات
اللي فيهما بعد حتى في بدايه الاحتجاجات
كان دائما الحديث همم
يستطيع النظام الايراني يحتوائه له موقف
سيكون كم اسبوع بدنا نحتجاجات ويرجع
الامور الى الطبيعي ان هذا كان بالفعل
الحديث اللي كان يدارك ولكن شعر ايراني
بما انه اقتنع انه لازم هو يغير مصير حتى
ولو كان هذا على حساب مخالفه المجتمع
الدولي لانه لديهم حس- حساباتهم وتخوفهم
من اسقاط النظام وممكن احداث احداث فوقها
في ايران همم مستمرين ولكن ما قدم
الدعم الدولي هل لديه مقومات كافيه داخليا
نيه او حال العراقيه يكون هناك مقاومه
شعبيه لهذا التغيير ولكن حتى وان كان هناك
دعم من الخارج حيكون مرحب من قبل النظام
الايراني
تسهيلاتها ولكن في النهايه من دون حتى دعم
الدولي خلال هذه الاشهر الشعب الايراني
افقد النظام الايراني خلال سنوات متتاليه
استطاعت النظام الايراني
النظام الايراني يضيق الخناق الان تحديدا
على المناطق الكرديه مما يخاف هل يخاف من
وصول هذا التمرد الى مرحله الحكم الذاتي ك
حصل في العراق
يعني ليست قضيه التمرد قضيه التمرد اللي
مهم في كردستان بسبب تنظيمهم السياسي يعني
في العاده في كردستان عندما تنظيمات
السياسيه تستدعي الشعب انه مثلا يعمل
اعتصامات او البازار يتسكر بالفعل هناك
استجابه شعبيه لهذه الطلبات هذا التنظيم
السياسي يخوف نظام الايراني يعني هناك
احزاب سياسيه كرديه لديها امكانيه التي
تقود حركه سياسيه لكل ايران لا تكون فقط
لكردستان كمال لديهم بعد هذا ممكن نقول
همم
الدافعيه وهذه الميول انه يكون لديهم دور
قيادي اكثر لكل ايران وليست منطقه كردستان
وايضا هذا الدعم الشعبي لكل ايران
لكردستان لذلك النظام الايراني المتخوف
جدا اذا استمر ويتمدد هذه التنظيم وهذا
الدعم الكبير لباقي المناطق الايرانيه
شكرا جزيلا لك ممثلاوي الباحثه في شان
الايراني من بروكسل تحياتي اليك
[موسيقى]
الى كوريا الشماليه الان تظهر هناك مجددا
ابنه
الزعيم تظهر الى جانبه خلال اطلاق
باقوى صاروخ استراتيجيه في العالم ظهور هو
الثاني للفتاه بعد ان ظهرت للمره الاولى
الاسبوع الماضي
الاول ذكر والثانيه والثالثه من الاناث في
حين ان من ظهرت معه هي الابنه الوسطى
ويعتقد انها ولدت عام 2013
وصفت وكاله الانباء المركزيه الكوريه
الفتاه بانها الاكثر قربا الى قلبك ميم
والطفله العزيزه ومحبوبه وهي الوحيده من
اولاده التي ظهرت في شكل رسمي
ظهور المتكرر يصير تكهنات طبعا بانه يتم
اعداد الفتاه لتكون خليفه لوالدها بالضبط
كما كان يتم اعداده هو ليخلف والده الزعيم
الراحل
لا يزال صغيرا لكن حصل على القاب كبيره
بدات بالرفيق اللامع حتى وصل الى المرشد
الاعلى للبلاد بعد وفاه والده بينما يقول
ينضجين الاستاذ في جامعه دراسات كوريا
الشماليه في سول ان وجود ابنتي يهدف الى
تصوير صاروخ الجديد الذي
سيتم اطلاقه على انه حلم جيل المستقبل
عده ليستخدمها في الدعايه لقوه نظامه
[موسيقى]
في هذه الاحتفاليه لاطلاق الصاروخ اكد
الزعيم الكوري الشمالي ان بلاده تعتزم ان
تكون اقوى قوه استراتيجيه في العالم من
اجل حمايه كرامه الدوله
على الوصول الى القوه المطلقه التي لم
يسبق لها اي مثيل في القرن الذي نعيش فيها
وكاله الانباء الرسميه اكدت ان عمليه
الاطلاق تلك اثبتت للعالم بوضوح ان كوريا
الشماليه هي قوه نوويه بالكامل كذلك اطلقت
الوكاله سما الوحش على الصاروخ الجديد
وقالت انه قادرون على الوصول الى الاراضي
الامريكيه لكن كوريا الشماليه قادره على
الوصول للاراضي الامريكيه بالفعل ذلك
الذي اطلقته عام 2017 تذكرون اننا نتحدثنا
عنه كثيرا
لكن يبدو ان الهدف من الصاروخ الجديد هو
اثبات ان كوريا الشماليه هي اقوى دوله
تمتلك صواريخ بالستيا عابره للقارات
اللافت ان هذه التطورات تاتي بعد دعوه
الرئيس الصيني لزعيم كوريا الشماليه
بالتعاون من اجل تسريع السلام في العالم
حيث اكد الرئيس الصيني
ان العالم يتغير بشكل غير مسبوق وانه
مستعد للتعاون معكم بشكل ايجابي لتحقيق
السلامه في المنطقه قبل نحوي اسبوعين
حينما التقى الرئيس الامريكي الرئيس
الصيني طلبه ايضا بابلاغ كوريا الشماليه
بوضوح بضروره عدم اجراء تجربه نوويه جديده
يبدو ان رساله
الى زعيم كوريا الشماليه ويبدو ان الاخيره
ايضا لم يهتم بها كثيرا
[موسيقى]
تتابعون معنا في العربيه 360 ايضا يدعو
الاوروبيين الى التحمل في سبيل دعم
اوكرانيا
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد
ان تسجيلات المستخدمين الجدد للمنصه بلغت
اعلى مستوياتها على الاطلاق
تحديدا عن الاعلان فيها
[موسيقى]
مؤامره مصر منصه كتويتر عرضتها لهجره
العقول وخساره المستخدمين هو الاخطر
خلافات مع افضل العلامات التجاريه
والمسوقين في العهد المطرب لتويتر عرض قسم
الاعلانات لدى الشركه الذي يجني 5 مليارات
دولار سنويا الى ضربه قويه
جميع العلامات التجاريه الكبرى اوقفت
مؤقتنا الانفاق على تويتر مستشهدين بالجزع
من نهج ماسك بمراقبه المحتوى وفصل العديد
من فريق مبيعات الاعلانات قسم الاعلانات
بتويتر تعرض ايضا لضربه الموجعه بعد عده
موجات من عمليات الفصل والاستقالات ادت
لنقص حاد بالموظفين وباتت العديد من
الوكالات لا تملك نقطه اتصال مع تويتر
يجد نفسه تحت ضغوط تحقيق الارادات حيث
يواجه مدفوعات بفائده سنويه بقيمه مليار
دولار بعد تحميل الشركه قدره 13 مليار
دولار للمساعده في تمويل استحواذه على
الشركه رغم تلك الحقائق كلها لا يزال
الملياردير ينظر بتفاؤل للعصفور الازرق
ويغرد عبره بابرز انجازاته على صعيد
المستخدمين يقول ماسك ان تسجيلات
المستخدمين الجدد بلغت اعلى مستوياتها
بمتوسط اكثر من مليونين شخص يوميا في
الايام السبعه الماضيه اعتبارا من السادس
عشر من نوفمبر و بنسبه 66% مقارنه
بالاسبوع نفسه من العام الماضي وما يقرب
من ثمانيه مليارات دقيقه الناشط يوميا
للمستخدمين في الايام السبعه الماضيه
اعتبارا من الخامس عشر من نوفمبر وبالنسبه
30% مقارنه بنفس الاسبوع من العام الماضي
اما خطاب الكراهيه على تويتر فبات اقل
بقرابه الثلث اعتبارا من الثالث عشر من
نوفمبر مقارنه بمنتصف اكتوبر من العام
الماضي بانخفاض من 10 الى مليونين ونصف
المليون الا ان النظر تتفاؤليه لالون ماسك
تجاه منصته الرقميه كانت تناقض ارقاما
اخرى فقد كشف تقرير لمركز مكافحه الكراهيه
الرقبيه ان استخدام الاهانات العنصريه على
تويتر ارتفع ثلاثه اضعاف المقارنه
بالاعوام السابقه منذ استحواذ الى الماسك
على المنصه واتهم الاتحاد الاوروبي وتويتر
بالفشل في ازاله خطاب الكراهيه
[موسيقى]
اخبار السيئه
اليوم في العربيه 3 62 هي من روسيا
الانطلاق قطار سانتا كلوز الروسيه قبل
اعياد راس السنه وذلك لزياره الاطفال كما
اعلنت السكه الحديد الروسيه اذا سانتا
كلوز في روسيا يطلق عليه ضد ماروزا اي جد
الصقيع ومن المقرر ان يسير القطار الذي
يعمل بالفحم لمسافه 13,000 كيلو مامات حيث
ذو سته و30 مدينه روسيه اللي يشعر الجميع
باقتراب العام الجديد
ويطلق الكثير من الانبعاثات الكربونيه في
رحلته الطويله كما تشاهدون لكن تحافظ
السكك الروسيه على هذا التقليد من اجل جعل
الرحله اشبه القصص الخياليه وهو كذلك صحيح
صحيح
تصريح اليوم في العربيه 360 هو للامين
العام لحلفي شمال الاطلسيوم في حديثه
للصحيفه الالمانيه فالت ام جون
باكبرنيا في حربها مع روسيا مكلف للغايه
بالنسبه لسكان الدول الغربيه لكن يجب
الحفاظ على تعزيز المساعدات
من الاسر الاوروبيه تعيش اوقات صعبه لكن
يجب زياده المساعده للاوكرانيين رغم ذلك
الى فيديو اليوم من العربيه 360 وهو من
ايطاليا بالتحديد جزيره ايسكي يا جنوب
البلاد والتي شهدت انهيارا ارضيا ضخما
بسبب الامطار الغزيره وكشفت فرق الطوارئ
الان جودها من اجل البحث عن احد عشر
مفقودا حيث يبحث الغطاسون في البحر عن
المفقود وحدث لانهيار الارضي بعد انفصلت
موجه من الطين والحطام والحجاره عن اعلى
جبل
ثم تدحرجت فوق المنازل والطرق